getting to sit down with those guys
getting to know them and getting to know
how they process football and how they
understand football is is really
important the football world is mourning
a lot
I'm or an assistant NFL coach and Son of
long time coach Mike Zimmer has died he
was 38.
Adam's sister Corey announced his death
on Instagram Tuesday writing quote I
can't believe I'm writing this I lost my
big brother yesterday Adam I love you so
much and I will miss you every second of
every day until I see you again please
watch over us and help us be okay the
cause of Adam's death has yet to be
revealed but the football Community is
showing an outpouring of love the
Minnesota Vikings tweeted their
heartbroken over Adam's death and in a
statement remembered him as a kind
respectful man Vikings quarterback Kirk
Cousins also paid tribute calling Adam a
tremendous coach and person quote had
the privilege of sitting next to him
flying back from games learned so much
to me I really like to learn to when I
we sit down with these guys how smart
they are and how they process football
you know you can
watch them go through drills all you
want to me I like grading on tape and
learning how much they know football
because in our defense you have to be a
smart football player Adam has a long
history with the Vikings he joined the
organization in 2014 when his dad was
hired as their head coach Adam was their
linebackers coach until 2020 when he was
promoted to co-defensive coordinator a
role he stayed in until 2021 when his
dad left the team do you ever see
yourself defensively of course calling
plays like on the sideline and and Mike
the head coach what makes him so good at
um at calling plays in the game yeah I
think eventually I do see myself doing
that in 2020 Adam opened up about
learning from his father and his
aspirations to someday follow in his
footsteps as a head coach I think it's
something I'm working towards uh every
day you know you think and you just even
talking football with Coach you know
what would you call here or what would
you call in this situation I think is
really really great for me to learn from
because you know he thinks about a lot
in a little amount of time and he's so
good at it and it just comes naturally
for him now after you know 40 Years of
doing it or however money